so i know you've had
some experience working with directing
duos before i think it was sin
city uncertainty in the interview so
what was it about ariel and henry's way
of working together on set
that made it stand out from those other
collaborations you've experienced before
the first thing i saw of henry and
rell's was this short film where they
got tom waits to narrate
um uh uh uh this tribute to an artist
named john
uh balthazari and it had
so much rhythm and wit and style
i was just like this is brilliant
whatever these guys are doing i'm i'm
curious um and uh you know recently
with me i i actually took the last
couple years off of acting
and my first job back was
this movie called 7500 which is very
intense
serious drama and after doing that i
just wanted to do something fun
and when i read the script for project
power and
uh thought it was going to be jamie foxx
and henry and rel
and new orleans i was like this will
probably
be fun and it was and i think that's why
it's fun to watch
i've also got to ask a little bit about
your collaboration
with dominique because your chemistry in
the movie is
hands down one of my favorite parts of
it so was there a moment
on set where it was earlier on in the
process and you kind of just felt that
click
and you knew it was going to work with
the two of you together
i'm so glad you brought her up because
she's she's my favorite part of this
movie
and uh i you know anybody out there
who's into
movies and acting and who's interested
in an up-and-coming talent you have to
check out
project power just to see dominique
fishback
we were really keen on making sure that
the relationship between
my character and her character was was
clearly something special
and uh from the from the first
time we met we we were rehearsing and we
decided to
um to just do some improv about how
these two met
because they're an unlikely pair it's a
high school student and a
detective and uh we wanted to kind of go
through and experience the backstory of
okay how did these two meet
how did they become friends how did they
come to care about each other
and so we did it we we went through like
okay the first time they met was like
this and then
they saw each other again and they ended
up staying in touch and here's why and
here's how that went and
after having gone through all that we've
we had this history in place that we had
we had experienced and i think you can
feel that when
even in our first scene you don't the
audience doesn't know anything yet about
their relationship but we we knew it and
and i think you can feel that when
you're watching oh you absolutely can to
close this out here
i'm not going to ask you about your
dream power that you would want the pill
to unlock but instead
what is the most boring but practical
power you would
really want and would think would come
in handy doing the dishes
if i could like have the the superpower
of just
all the dishes are done they're just
done it's a
miracle that that would um
that would make me happy that would make
me really happy thanks so much for
talking with me again
and huge congratulations on another
movie all right thanks a lot good to
talk to you